we have some more of your suggestions on  what to do with 100 mile an hour  speeders pretty incredible suggestions  here linda writes in you know when  someone's speeding twice the speed limit  or over 100 miles an hour confiscate the  vehicle maybe jail time 70 and a 35 just  as bad as 100 on the freeway but check  this out she writes let them watch their  car  being crushed  okay here's another one from carol and  this is pretty wild whatever punishment  100 mile an hour drivers get should  include a mandatory month of looking at  police photos of fatal crashes that are  not seen by the public  linda carroll thank you for writing you  got something to say feel free to chime  in we'll keep sharing your comments the  email address oh first of all buckle up  drive carefully please put down that  phone the email address is traffic 8  8newsnow.com